why is it that human females go through
menopause because I don't think that
most other animals do hardly any the
theory is that humans over time began to
become more and more long-lived if the
mother is taking care of her children
and then her grandchildren her bearing
another child there's the danger shield
in childbirth or that she'll die when
that child is Young if we live in social
groups we take care of the members of
our group it's our genes making an
economic decisions Hillary Kaplan a
number of people have analyzed things
like the calories that are brought in by
people over their lifespan in the
Horticultural groups living sort of
close to the ancestral circumstances the
average couple doesn't really bring in
enough calories to care for themselves
and their children and so they need
their relatives to help them out and
their neighbors to help them out it pays
for the female to stop reproducing
because she's still in this group or
she's still sharing calories and time
and resources but she's no longer
continuing to produce more mouths that
need feeding right exactly